Russia is revoking its ratification of a
global nuclear test ban President
Vladimir Putin signed the bill into law
on Thursday abandoning The Landmark
agreement the treaty which was adopted
in 1996 banned all nuclear explosions
including tests of nuclear
weapons for more on this now alzer's
Moscow Bureau correspondent Julia
shapovalova joins us on set good to have
you here in the studio in dah for a
change so Julia why is Russia
withdrawing from this treaty
well Russia explains that um there is a
situation now when it needs to act in
its national interests and inance
interests of its people so uh we're also
hearing from chairman of uh the Russian
State Duma which is uh um Russia's lower
housee of parliament VAV vodin is saying
that uh now it the the country uh it was
a mirror response to the actions of the
United States uh which had not ratified
this document for 23 years and the
decision was made solely in the interest
of Russia and the Russian people and you
said the interests of the people what
are they being explicit in what interest
they feel is being compromised well
they're not explaining that really but
we understand that as you mentioned
Russia actually uh signed and
immediately ratified the treaty back in
1996 and uh interesting that um
countries like the United States China
and Israel they did sign it back in 1996
but ever since have never ratified it
and countries like North Korea
um Pakistan and India they neither
signed it nor ratified it so basically
uh we first heard about Russia's desire
to do so from President Vladimir Putin
at a meeting of valde um Club disc the
the meeting of the Val discussion Club
back in October so basically that was
the time when he announced that the
nuclear Test Ban Treaty uh would be um
May actually take place so basically
that was quite alarming for for many and
this is not the first incident we had of
withdrawals is it I was looking back a
few years ago the United States withdrew
from the intermediate range nuclear
forces treaty is the whole movement that
the world was in a few decades to go
towards signing agreements to get rid of
nuclear weapons is that all unraveling
now well absolutely so as we understand
the world depends well among other
things the world depends on a number of
treaties like uh the nonproliferation of
nuclear weapons treaty the reduction of
strategic offensive weapons treaty and
others and basically over the years uh
we've seen how countries have been
abandoning and withdrawing from those
treaties making the world a less safe
place and right now we see that how you
know contradictions between uh world
powers and nuclear countries and
nonclear countries they're trying to um
decide uh regarding nuclear disarmament
uh process and I mean all those those
issues are becoming extremely acute but
obviously it is a very dangerous sign to
see how the idea of peace and stability
in the world is shrinking and on that
point Julia what's the bottom line here
what does this mean for the
proliferation of nuclear weapons and how
safe the world is well basically we're
starting getting some International
reactions on that but uh some
Specialists say that uh um other
countries may go ahead and start
conducting underground tests under after
Russia but having said that that uh we
hear from a number of Russian officials
uh saying that despite Russia's decision
uh to canel the nuclear tban treaty
ratification the country will continue
to fulfill its obligations under the
treaty as well as to observe a
moratorium on uh the nuclear tests and
according to the Russian um um according
to the Russian foreign ministry as well
Russia will only agree to go ahead and
conduct nuclear tests only if the US
basically take such a step first which
is also quite worrying all right good to
have you on set thanks so much jul
shavala